make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoyed the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and i'm
not even gonna lie about donnie kate's
neo initially when donnie kate started
venom and he did like thanos wins and
stuff like that
but a lot of donnie kate's early work
was like mini series and so there was a
part of me that was looking at his venom
run and
and i wouldn't say that i thought he was
a one-off but a lot of times you see
writers who do like a mini-series they
do really well they get a character they
do really well then they switch over to
somebody else and they do terrible
a really good example of this is brian
michael bendis who wrote some really
good stuff in marvel then he went to dc
wrote superman and it was garbage and so
it was it was a i was a little hesitant
i'm not even gonna lie i was a little
hesitant when donnie kate started
writing thor
but between like the devourer king and i
was just like dude this is amazing and
then pray
this second story arc it's awesome right
so here's the thing what i want to do
here is i want to explain something
really quick when it comes to the nature
of donald blake in marvel comics right
so donald blake as most of you guys know
was the original identity or the alter
ego that thor had when he first started
appearing in marvel comics right the
idea was that
somewhere along the line odin decided
thor was too haughty and
arrogant and so he basically ended up uh
creating a kind of fictional persona in
the form of donald blake and then
confined thor
to that identity on earth and then like
a decade after that he discovered the
the walking stick in the cave and then
he struck it on the ground and then he
got the hammer and then over time his
memory started coming back right thor
159 by stan lee and jack kirby is the
first time that you really get the full
on origin
of thor in terms of how it relates to
like the donald blake identity and all
that kind of stuff but over the years in
marvel there were a lot of attempts to
cast aside the donald blake persona and
replace it with somebody else right so
if you go into tom defalco's run you get
eric masterson
you go into dan jurgens run you get jake
olson and it was just attempt to like
replace donald blake and to say like
okay well eric masterson will be the
identity of thor now and then like jake
olson who is a paramedic will be the
identity of thor and by and large there
were some other things that kind of went
into it right you had like shattered
heroes where like donald blake came back
kind of a continuation from what
happened when he returned during uh j
michael sterzinski's run on thor the
reality of what
uh what donnie case is doing here is
essentially wiping all that away
or a good portion of it anyway um eric
masterson remains a few things remain
here um and we'll make sense of this as
we kind of go on but he also seems to
sort of eliminate the entire concept of
shattered heroes which in reality i have
no complaints about that story was kind
of terrible when it came to thor but the
cool thing about this is that donnie
kate's kind of
kind of kicks things off and says okay
so like the notion of donald lake is
that he first appeared you know it's
kind of the alternate identity of thor
he was created by odin that kind of a
thing and the big question that a lot of
people kind of had
at least in the early days before it was
really fleshed out by walt simonsen and
other writers even though it wasn't
really hammered out in
in any real fine and meaningful way is
that whenever thor
changes into donald blake where does
donald blake go right we knew where thor
went and we were kind of given that
answer to a degree
in uh in in j michael strzenski's thor
in the sense that when
thor odinson changes into uh into donald
blake that thor goes to a kind of
afterlife right like a realm of
nothingness so to speak where he like
communes with the
the past gods and things like that so
think of it as something as like the
thor equivalent to when like black
panther communes with the the
you know former black panthers of his
realm in the marvel cinematic universe
it's something akin to that and then
when donald blake turned into thor
we kind of got this little bit of an
explanation from j michael strozinski's
but it was just kind of
thrown away right by a lot of marvel
riders that came after him and so what
we're basically told here by donnie
cates is that whenever
thor turns into donald lake thor goes to
wherever he's supposed to go but when
donald blake turns back into thor
donald blake basically goes he goes to a
paradise right he goes to this realm
that was created under the under the
tree of idrisil by odin
where it's basically a paradise right
where and and it's one of these things
where it wasn't really supposed to be
there for eternity right it was it was
one of these things where like they
would kind of routinely change back and
forth and odin didn't really seem to
give a whole lot of thought to this
concept
but it looked like a paradise
everlasting it basically stretched on
for infinity and the reality was
whenever donald blake was here
time really had no meaning so he
wouldn't really know how much time had
passed between
the moments when he was thor and when he
was here um the reason why that didn't
really matter
in the past was because thor and donald
lake would switch places so often
that even if like a week or two would
pass it would be like that and it would
take virtually no time for for donald
lake to catch up on what he had
essentially missed but what's basically
been going on here
that thor has been for for so long and
donald blake has been in that realm for
so long
that a huge amount of time has passed
well there's actually another caveat to
this so you end up having this kind of
meeting between loki and and odin son
and and thor just kind of petitions loki
and says hey man like i need to go on a
personal journey that kind of thing i
need you to keep an eye out for you know
i out on asgard for me and loki keeps
trying to get thor to spill the beans
because loki really knows what's going
on and thor is a little hesitant to do
it and then loki's like okay fine so he
basically grabs the hammer and then
throws it it throws it at thor now this
is not designed to be like oh my god
loki lifted the hammer four
wow you know it's not designed to be
that way instead the notion that other
people can lift thor's hammer uh beyond
someone who is worthy
uh is really kind of an on running plot
thread in what donnie cates has been
doing
that the the asgardian magics that bind
the hammer and all that kind of stuff
have been breaking down right ever since
he became the new owner
the magic that binds asgard the magic
that determines who can wield the hammer
and who can't it's all kind of eroding
we don't really know why
we just know that it is and so because
loki had figured it out he's like okay
so like you want to know why this is
happening and the response with thor
is basically yes and i want to go on a
journey to figure out why and look is
kind of like okay fine
uh then like we can do that right like
you go commune with the elder gods and
talk to them and find out what's
happening
and i'll keep an eye out here and
basically make sure everything's okay
the problem with this
is that thor was supposed to transition
to this this kind of elder guard realm
instead when he strikes the hammer on
the ground he falls through that realm
and then lands in the realm of donald
blake and when he gets there
everybody's dead right it's just a
massacre like everything's just kind of
gone to pandemonium and it looks like by
all standards of measurement donald
blake has lost his mind and in fact he
has because what we end up learning
is that the the the world serpent has
basically been killed here right it's
been destroyed here
by donald blake himself which is
something that's thought to have been
insurmountable for a couple reasons
one because the world servant was never
meant to be able to access this area and
two
uh because donald blake was just a guy
and so there's no real indication
because as soon as
as soon as they switch places donald
blake is all disheveled right and he's
literally got a suit of armor made out
of the hide
of like of the world serpent and loki is
like you're not supposed to be here in
this way like that's not supposed to
like i mean sure you're supposed to be
here but like not like this
and so as soon as loki realizes
something's up he goes to attack donald
blake and donald blake overpowers loki
so fast and is kind of nuts right i mean
literally just starts like he snaps his
arm
and just starts tearing him apart right
he's like i am not thor right and i
never will be again he literally takes
his walking stick
and snaps it in half now the
significance of this is that if the
walking stick is broken
there's no way for thor to return to the
realm of the living basically he cut off
thor's access point that's the only way
right the the walking stick has to be
hit on the ground struck on the ground
and then that'll cause donald blake and
thor to switch back donald blake knows
this
destroys the walking stick though we're
stuck in that realm right there's no way
to bring him back and so from there you
have donald lake who kind of goes and
starts grabbing weapons but then also
looking
at like the books that have been written
regarding like the legends of thor
that's why you see references
to like jake olson you see references to
thunderstrike here because what this
basically meant is that like
other people have been playing the role
of thor outside of donald blake and the
donald blake has seemingly just been
confined to this realm for
so long and has essentially gone insane
but there is actually another caveat
right there's another thing that kind of
comes into this the funny thing about it
is that as soon as donald blake is here
and then once word has reached the ears
of the asgardians that he overpowered
loki then you have the arrival of sith
volstag and beta ray built and you would
think now that these three would easily
be able to overpower donald blake and
and
for the most part they would be right in
assuming so because donald blake is just
a regular guy or he's just supposed to
be but somehow or another donald blake's
power has been elevated to the point
that he can take out loki which is no
small feat right one thing to keep in
mind
loki challenged doctor strange for the
role of sorcerer supreme right so
being able to channel and use that much
power is a huge thing and having donald
blake being able to overpower him
is an even bigger thing and so when you
have sif and vader ray bill
and uh and wolfstack who go to challenge
and try to take on donald blake he
wrecks them all now here's the funny
thing about this he's not just like
fighting them the way that a warrior
normally would right the way that you
would see
uh you know beta ray bill or siff or
wolfstag fight instead
he fights with precision right he's got
his own little scalpel that's his weapon
and he fights
swift and quickly and making small
little cuts small little jabs here and
there and it's one of the things where
because he's able to move
so fast and able to overpower these guys
so quickly he takes them all down the
crazy thing about this though is is kind
of like the big revelation that comes
with him is he
strips beta ray bill of the enchantment
given to him
by odin right basically a fraction of
the odin force is stripped from beta ray
bill and then absorbed in a donald lake
himself
and once they're all overpowered they in
turn call for reinforcements and donald
blake
rips through all these reinforcements
too right he basically grabs yarnbjorn
the the celestially empowered axe and
just
cuts a swath through everybody just his
he's just swathing
swathing through everybody but he's
basically cutting through
every single one of these guys and
that's a crazy thing here because
literally it's this entire asgardian
army or seemingly
everybody here that could lay waste him
or could in some form or fashion destroy
him he basically takes them all out he
then takes the sword of sif
and then uses it to transport the realm
or transport everybody on asgard
directly to like the blood dimension
right now the blood dimension was a
dimension that was kind of given to us
it appeared quite some time in marvel
comics it went back a little ways
um really to the doctor strange stories
that we got but it was really just kind
of a realm
where you ended up having loki and
doctor strange where they were fighting
they ended up like taking their fight to
this realm
and then like things popped off and
doctor strange turned like half the
population into bunny rabbits it was
weird but that's kind of where you get
that little bit of a realm from but for
donald blake himself because
all the inhabitants of uh of asgard have
kind of been teleported away from
asgardia itself he's the only real
occupant there and so now it's kind of
like okay like let's go visit some
people right let's go find some folks
and visit some friends and so from there
you switch over to thor talking to the
world serpent and what you end up
finding out here is the world serpent
had basically managed to find a way
into this realm even though he wasn't
supposed to and then he went to donald
blake and revealed the reality of donald
blake to donald himself now this is
something that a quote unquote
previously been done
especially during the shadowed heroes
thing and that's why i say it really
looks like donnie case is just kind of
removing and ignoring all of that and
and really just basically saying that
the revelation of donald blake's life as
being one that was fabricated by odin
for the purpose of making thor humble
drives donald blake insane right it
drives him nuts now
the whole idea behind this was to reveal
to donald lake that because he was
created by odin he possesses a fraction
of the odin force right as a construct
it's like the story of like adam and eve
right that eve was created from a bone
of adam therefore eve is part adam
uh which really kind of begs the
question is that like an incestuous
relationship but regardless that uh it's
one of these things where because of the
fact that donald blake was created by
odin he possesses a portion of odin's
power
and waking donald blake up to that
donald blake in turn hated the fact that
his life was fake it drove him insane
then he attacked the world serpent and
then stole the power of the world
serpent and then killed him right so
donald blake is basically running around
with the with the odin force that's
essentially what's happening here right
now that's why donald blake is so
powerful and that's why he's able to to
essentially like overpower
everybody in asgard and so what you end
up having is it's kind of switching back
to donald
because of the fact that he's so pissed
off his mission is to essentially punish
and or destroy
everything related to thor and so he
ends up visiting a hospital to run into
jane
foster and so the two of them actually
end up sitting down and kind of having
dinner together and things are
are you know i mean they're they're you
know donald blake's not really revealing
anything but it's not as though he
immediately goes and attacks her instead
it's one of these things where he kind
of sees her
as a potential means to an end but there
was also a romantic relationship between
the two so in some ways it really kind
of seems like he's just visiting an old
friend here but one of the crazy things
that goes on
is when when you know jane foster
reveals that she was thor at one point
and that kind of drives
like that drives down a blank insane
because he's like wait no what you were
thor and then like you know that kind of
has this dream revelation where he
attacks jane foster
and like rips the thor rips the the
power of thor out of her right the
reality of this is she doesn't really
contain that power anymore it was one of
the things that marvel did in the
aftermath
of jason aaron's run as incredible and
amazing as it was and as much as i would
have liked to have seen jane foster stay
thor
like i've always said in comics the more
things change the more they stay the
same right so
you basically ended up having odin's son
going back to playing the role of thor
i kept telling people that people were
complaining about jane foster being thor
so i saw those people who were
as one of two things
either they weren't really familiar with
comics and they didn't really know that
like things would go back to normal or
they did know that and they were just
looking for a reason to be pissed off
right so um you know because of the
because of what's gone on with jane
because she's not really thor she's a
valkyrie now
ultimately it's just a wholly different
role that's provided for her
and so donald blake is just kind of like
okay like i have to go but i have to
leave
sensing the fact that she doesn't really
have the power of thor and is not really
tied to the odin force anymore
and instead donald blake almost kind of
takes a bit of arrogance and anger
towards her right in the sense of saying
like like you loved me once not him
right like you
you know you used to love me you didn't
love thor you don't belong as like a
morgue's assistant right you should go
on and do something better in this world
and so what you end up having here
is the body of roger norvell which shows
up in the morgue now roger norvell was a
guy who previously defeated thor now
he kind of had like the belt of strength
and these gauntlets and that was really
during like roy thomas and john
bessima's run on thor back in thor
273 i think it was it was okay right it
wasn't that great of a story but
the long and short of this is he was a
person who was previously thought and so
jane foster starts to put two and two
together and come to this realization
that with donald blake seemingly showing
up out of nowhere and then somebody who
had previously played thor
being killed and then you know donald
blake almost having this sort of of
anger and rage towards her kind of
vindictiveness
she comes to the realization that donald
blake is basically going around and
killing thor's and that's when we have
donald blake who confronts
throgg right now throgg of course was a
version of thor who became a frog and
then ultimately was given his own
identity just because of the fact that
you know it was an amazing concept
thor becoming a frog was one of the
coolest things initially it was loki
turning thor into a frog and then again
you know marvel kind of gave throg his
own role it was cool right it was a
really really cool moment in a cool
series of stories back during simonsen's
run
but uh but what you end up having here
is literally donald blake who's being
overpowered by frog and it's kind of
nuts because it's a combination of throg
and lockjaw right because it was
basically like you know the pet avengers
which was an amazing story for marvel
comics but it was basically just like
the pet avengers right so like lockjaw
and like frog and a few other people
like the horse of valkyrie it was it was
cool right it was it was an awesome
concept
um but basically like between lockjaw's
ability to teleport and
throg having his own hammer having his
own mjolnir they're kind of able to hold
their own against donald blake uh now it
does get to the point where donald blake
like eats throgg and then just goes to
attack lockjaw and then like throgs
hammer just comes flying out of the
mouth of donald blake and then throb
jumps out he's like you really think you
could eat me man
you really think that's what was going
to happen and so they kind of go
toe-to-toe now of course
throgg basically ends up overpowering
donald blake by like smashing him in the
face
and then kind of knocking him
unconscious and then he tells lockjaw
like we need to get this guy somewhere
right like i know i know a doctor that
can take care of these kinds of things
but you also have uh you also have jane
foster who's going to visit doctor
strange as well right because she's
trying to find out where the actual thor
is and of course getting a hold of one
of the avengers is the only real way to
do it kind of a nice little touch here
she does go to call tony stark but
because of the fact that odin's son
because thor had written tony stark's
number
on the side of the hammer in that little
two-part story we did where like the old
man calls thor because he lifts his
hammer that tony stark basically can't
he just kind of canceled his number i
mean it's there he just has a voicemail
it's a throwaway phone number and he got
a different number instead
so kind of a small funny little
reference of donnie kate's referencing
his own work but then like frog comes
flying out of a window and then like
lockjaw comes flying out of a window too
and then you have uh then you have like
donald lake overpowering doctor strange
right which makes sense if he's got the
odin force right he's way beyond doctor
strange at this point and so then like
jane you know jane foster turns into
valkyrie goes to try to attack donald
blake donald blake teleports away and so
that's when it's kind of like okay
this guy's level of power is on a whole
new a whole new level now right
like it's it's kind of nuts and so
ultimately you have donald blake turning
his attention to basically destroying
the or you know attacking the world tree
and the reason why is because
going through and attacking these
various forces out there these various
foes who have played the role of thor
well for the most part you know getting
a hold of throg is one of these things
where it was difficult because of the
sheer amount of power his other response
is then i'm just gonna go and i'm just
gonna attack uh i'm just gonna like try
to summon odin right if i start
attacking the world tree odin's gonna
have to respond there's no way odin
would just sit and allow the world tree
to be destroyed the problem with this is
that as he destroys the world tree
because the realm that donald lake was
in exists below the world tree and
because thor odin's son
is there thor odinson is basically being
kind of like flooded with this power of
the world tree of idris
it's basically being being flooded with
like the power of the multiverse is is
kind of what it is to a degree and so
ultimately you end up having jane foss
who's like fine like we got to go get
odin right it's one of these things
where they're all kind of leading to the
same place
and so she's like we have to go find
this guy odin started this odin's the
only one who can really end it and so
what she ends up doing is basically
traveling to like this this really
unknown destination or unlisted
destination
and finds odin getting drunk in a bar
now here's the important thing to
understand here right this is odin as a
ceremonial role odin gave his power to
thor when odin made thor king of asgard
he basically gave him the odin force so
this is not odin
in all of his power but i will say man
biker odin
looks amazing because that's basically
what he is right biker odin let me tell
you something man if if odin goes back
to being like the ruler of asgard this
is the guy i want to see running asgard
right dude this guy looks like a member
of hell's angels it's amazing
[Laughter]
it's so cool now one of the things
that's also kind of thrown out here and
we're not really given a whole lot of
explanation
is that with everything that's happened
with odin over the years
that odin is kind of you know he seems
to have kind of lost himself in a lot of
ways and initially you had freya who is
responding in different ways right the
struggle of the two of them kind of
trying to pull it together so it was
like impacting their marriage they were
talking to a marriage counselor i didn't
know asgard had those and i certainly
didn't know that odin needed one but
then freya takes more of a heavy-handed
approach then she takes more of a softer
approach and then ultimately she ends up
leaving right and so by the time that
odin kind of managed to get himself
together to a degree that he essentially
ended up just kind of losing his wife
right and so was just kind of there by
himself and seemed to kind of give up
right and ultimately pass the power onto
thor and so there's a little bit of
murkiness that goes on here with regards
to his character the only real aftermath
we saw with the war of realms was kind
of like the tie-in by jason aaron but
that focused more on thor than it did on
odin right so there's a few
unexplained questions here that
hopefully we'll get an explanation to
unless i've missed something right
unless i missed something huge but the
long and short of this is that you
basically have jane foster who's like
get it together man
we have a great big huge thing going on
here right like get it together odin
like get off your bottle get off your
ass and like let's go deuce let's go
solve this problem you know she's like
you created this your son's locked away
in some realm below
idracil he can't get out you literally
have donald blake who's just running
around
unleashing all kinds of health you gotta
do something dude and so you end up
having odin who's like okay fine right
odin kind of pulls it together and it's
like okay cool like i'll grab my armor
and we'll go do our thing when you have
that when you have that that takes place
one of the things that happened is while
you did have sif who was kind of hanging
out with beta ray bill the sort of
romantic attraction between the two of
them sort of developed here
i wouldn't say it was a strong romantic
attachment it wasn't like sift saw beta
ray bill is mr right it was more she saw
him as like mr right now
is basically what that was you know and
so like that's where she had the desire
to start banging him you know and so you
basically end up having like like loku
comes along
as well meets up with her doctor strange
and vader ray bill and it's like we got
to find a way to take down donald blake
right like right now he's destroying the
world tree he's unleashing holy hell
like we got to do something and so this
draws the attention of throgg along with
everybody else who basically show up
here
and they're able to kind of hold their
own or at least able to to attack donald
blake not necessarily overpower him in
the most extreme
instead when they arrive and he goes on
the attack that you end up having him
you know basically attacked
by by odin now here's the other thing
man like odin in his armor right now
looks even more amazing right like i
don't know if he looks more amazing than
like biker odin
okay give me your all's opinion which
one do you like better like armored odin
or
biker odin cause like i prefer biker
odin dude he looks badass
like i real it looks amazing
he looks so cool but yeah you know it's
one of these cool concepts
where odin is just kind of unleashing
hell right just kind of unleashing holy
hell or at least doing what he can't and
he even tells donald blake he's like
look man i mean i get that you're pissed
right i get that you're mad but here's
the problem that you have you've been
striking the power of the world tree
which is a power that has the ability to
create worlds get give life
enhance the power of gods let me ask you
something if the realm that you lived in
was below idrisil and and you've escaped
from it but you put thor there
then you started destroying idracil and
all this power is flowing into the world
below you what do you think it's
bleeding to and that's when you have
odin son who's just like
empowered by all this stuff right now
but here's here's
here's a caveat to this despite all this
power that odin's son has now
the power to like create and destroy
worlds he's still stuck down there
he's still stuck down there and so
ultimately he summons his ravens right
after kind of being able to reach out
kind of through this this fissure and
these cracks but his ravens are like we
can't bring you to this realm it's
beyond our power to do so he's like
that's true but you can take my essence
you can take my soul
into that realm and they're like yes but
you need a vessel he's like i know and i
have the perfect idea for it and so
while everything's popping off with
donald blake and you have like donald
lake who's getting ready to go and
attack odin suddenly
thor reappears this time in the
destroyer armor and then he's got like
destroyer written on the chest which is
epic as hell man it looks amazing it's
like it's like the thor version of
superboy prime
[Laughter]
it looks so cool so you basically got
you got the power of thor
with this kind of enhancement that came
from the the tree of idris which is
bolstered by the power of the destroyer
armor
and now he's going on a rampage to take
out donald blake now here's the funny
thing about this this is donald blake
with seemingly the full mind of the odin
force i wouldn't say it's like the
totality of it
because some of it's still inside of
thor but that's kind of one of the
things that donnie kate's plays with
if donald blake transfers if he if he
jumps to what is basically asgard thor's
confined in
the realm below idracil does all that
odin force power of thor
transfer itself to donald lake and the
answer seems to be yes right in fact
donald blake is able to use the
enchantment
or at least able to pick up the hammer
because the enchantment screwed up but
it's one of these things where it's not
like i'm
donald i'm donald blake and i've got the
hammer of thor you know it's nothing
like that he goes to talk trash and thor
is like nope and like punches the crap
out of him with the destroyer armor just
overpowers him and then it's just kind
of like this is done right no more words
no nothing this is completely and
totally finished and so so at that point
he goes to attack the destroyer armor
and then starts to siphon off the odin
force
from thor and he's like did you really
believe that for me a person who can
siphon off the odin force from pretty
much anybody who has it that the
destroyer armor would be able to
overpower me and so at that point odin's
like enough and he calls mjolnir to
himself
and the mjolnir is intercepted by beta
ray bill who finally gets it back and
it's like dude battery bill hasn't had
mjolnir in like 20 years man so like
it's so cool to see him back his like
old school beta ray bill this is why i
say man do donnie kate's dude
man man i'm gonna try some donnie kate's
done kate son man dude
it's nuts man it's it's amazing right
that's why i tell you guys man donnie
case's writing is legit
it's it's it's dude this guy can write
anything man like he's in my top three
favorite writers of all time now and so
he's just kind of like no right like
like i am owed a weapon right like thor
destroyed
my stormbreaker i am owed a weapon and i
will have
a weapon so he's like you know if if
stormbreaker's gone i'll take back
mjolnir right i've wielded it before
it's my hammer now right this is my
weapon now dude he starts spinning that
thing up and he's like let's get to it
now boys
dude it's it's it's it's amazing right
it's it's amazing
and so at that point like he immediately
goes like he just ends up flying to
donald blake which basically
distracts him and then you get this
really interesting moment here this is a
really interesting moment dr strange
summons the crimson bands of sidorak
which were able to ensnare donald blake
and then hold him in place this is while
donald blake has the odin force here's a
question that i would pose to you guys
if the crimson bands of sidorak can
ensnare someone who possesses the odin
force and then keep them confined
does that mean that the the entity
sidorak is more powerful than odin
that's my question
i don't know the answer to that because
there's a lot of a lot of variables here
right does donald lake have the full
totality of the odin force if he does
does he know how to use it in such a way
where he can overpower sidorak or
citarax the citavix power really just
greater than that of odin i don't know
the answer to that question you're
talking about two different beings who
have never met and who have never
actually fought each other so we don't
really know
the depths of that but ultimately when
when donald blake is just kind of like
confined
you know the whole idea of donald blake
is just like kill me right just make me
nothing like in this suffering of living
a life that was never my own right
knowing that i was just created for the
purpose
of like teaching a lesson to some guy in
this nothing life that i have like
destroy me and so you end up basically
having like both thor and loki who are
like no like odin do not do that like
do not kill him and so loki ends up
reconstituting the the walking stick of
donald blake
and then basically throwing it to thor
in his destroyer armor and then thor
smashes it on the ground and donald
blake vanishes before odin can kill him
right now of course thor takes his
hammer back but it's one of these things
where it's like you cannot kill him
right you cannot destroy him right
technically like he's a brother of mine
and then he just like
reads the riot act to odin right and
that's that's a crazy thing right like
odin's like this is my problem son i
should be the one to fix it and thor's
like yeah all of this is your fault
right all this is your fault pops but
understand
you are not the king of asgard anymore i
am i'm the one who runs the show here
you gave your power to me
so get the hell out of here right like
go and it's kind of
nuts to see thor talking to odin in that
way he's like i trust you can see your
way up and odin besieges thor as best he
can but thor's like i don't care like
we're gonna have a reckoning like make
no mistake
do not be confused about your place in
the bigger picture pops we're gonna have
a reckoning and you and i
you and i are gonna come to an
understanding you understand what i'm
saying like that's what's gonna happen
but at the moment i got bigger fish to
fry i've got bigger things to worry
about
and so ultimately odin basically ends up
leaving asgard right he's cast out yet
again and so donald blake is is just
kind of freed by not really freed and
allowed to go by
thor but one of these things where he's
kind of like you know understand like
you are you are made from my flesh right
you are made as a as a part of me
and therefore you are a brother unto me
and that's cool and everything but know
that like this kind of thing can't stand
and so he basically goes and attacks him
and we're not really attacking but like
has him struck by lightning and knocked
out and then he asks loki he's like what
should i do here you know like any and
he's like you know is
is like do you want me to lie you want
me to lie to you now right like you want
me to tell you like some falsehood or
something like that
like i'm going to take him somewhere and
i'm going to put him away and ultimately
thor is just kind of like
no like i don't want to know what you're
going to do with him but just get him
out of my sight right just handle it
right because loki's like i'll handle
this man
but do you really want to know what i'm
going to do and so because of that what
you end up having
is is donald blake basically becoming
the new god of lies and just taken below
you know to kind of encounter and deal
with the serpent where he's effectively
tied up chained up and sort of left
there forever more now the reality of
this
is this is donnie kate's putting donald
blake on the back burner so he can bring
him back at a future point in time
that's really all this is but because of
the fact that loki's no longer the god
of lies and he's a god of myths and
stories
that there has to always be a god of
lies and that's now donald blake who's
basically taken that role and he'll just
stay here and he'll suffer
for seemingly all eternity or until one
until someone frees him but this story
is amazing but with that being said guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the raw poor if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
foreign